annabelle's health has not been the same
since she caught covid last october
there are physical issues like the daily
headaches and debilitating fatigue
but helen worries more about the impact
kovid has had on her 10 year old's brain
and nervous system
the most debilitating part of of the
illness is
the extreme anxiety that that she
suffers it's like a different child
compared to this time
last year i don't feel like i've got
as much as i would have liked from the
curving incident
helen has been told the covid19
infection
has triggered a post-viral response
known as
pediatric acute onset neuropsychiatric
syndrome
or pans but there may be
some good news for annabelle
a new study shows children who become
ill with coronavirus
are unlikely to have long-term effects
with less than two percent having
symptoms lasting
more than eight weeks researchers from
king's college london
studied more than seventeen hundred
children they found symptoms
lasted an average of five to seven days
in children aged between
five and seventeen and fewer than one in
twenty experience symptoms
for four weeks or more this compares to
around one in seven
adults who experience symptoms for four
weeks or more
although overall the news is very
positive a small number of children and
families will need some support
and it's about talking to your gp who
could then refer
on to a pediatrician and then finding
the right
and individualized support the study's
authors say even children who suffer a
long illness with covert 19
usually recover with time
helen will hope annabelle does because
for now
every day is still a struggle
oh she's josh she's sky news